My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to become a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the declineside application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology
我叫 Diakalola Amujam。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。Marion 博士的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中提供了极大的帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我很喜欢阅读那些已获得资格和正在接受培训的临床心理学家的经历。各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学提供了惊人的见解。
journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. Have you ever been signed off work and then spent half your time feeling guilty for not working. You know you're unwell, your doctor knows you're unwell, you might even have the ability to tell someone else in exactly the same situation that they're not well and they shouldn't be working. But somehow when it's you, resting can feel suspiciously like failing. So why do we find it so difficult to be ill? I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and this is inner work. Hi, welcome along. There can be so many different reasons why you're signed off sick from work.
旅程。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。你是否曾经因为请病假而感到内疚，觉得自己在偷懒？你知道自己身体不适，医生也知道你身体不适，你甚至可能有能力告诉处于同样境地的人他们不舒服，不应该工作。但不知何故，当事情发生在自己身上时，休息会让人觉得像是失败。那么，为什么我们觉得生病这么难呢？我是 Marianne Trent 博士，这是《内在工作》（Inner Work）。嗨，欢迎收听。你请病假的原因可能有很多种。
And yet, of course, intellectually, we know that we're there for a reason, but it sometimes doesn't stop that sense that it feels like we're skiving, it feels like we should be doing more, or that we should still be at work, and it's not right. What we're going to look at today is kind of just to have a little examine of some of those thoughts and feelings. I think one of the tricky things is being able to imagine, you know, perhaps what your colleagues or other people doing the same job as you will be doing right now because you're usually part of that workforce. And we almost need to give ourselves permission to just allow them to be doing that whilst we are doing what we are doing. We don't need to be constantly
然而，从理智上讲，我们当然知道请假是有原因的，但这有时并不能阻止那种感觉——感觉我们在偷懒，感觉我们应该做得更多，或者我们应该还在工作，而现在这样是不对的。我们今天要探讨的是审视一下这些想法和感受。我认为棘手的事情之一是能够想象你的同事或其他做同样工作的人现在在做什么，因为你通常是那个团队的一部分。我们几乎需要给自己许可，允许他们在做那些事的同时，我们也做我们该做的事。我们不需要一直
comparing and contrasting because that's more likely to make it that you're coming up short. your job right now is to help yourself feel better or to rest or to heal. Their job is to be doing whatever they're doing. So we're just trying to encourage ourselves to stay in our own lane and not compare ourselves to them because it might well be that we're not going to measure up favourably to that. And even if you know that you've been in a really busy work environment and that, you know, it's going to be more stressful because you're not there, that just has to be accepted because right now you're not well enough to be at work for whatever reason that is.
进行比较和对照，因为那只会让你觉得自己做得不够。你现在的工作是帮助自己感觉好起来，或者休息，或者康复。他们的工作是做他们正在做的事情。所以我们只是试图鼓励自己专注于自己的事情，不要拿自己和他们比较，因为结果很可能是不利于你的。即使你知道你一直处于一个非常繁忙的工作环境中，而且你知道因为你不在，压力会更大，但这必须被接受，因为无论出于什么原因，你现在身体状况不足以去工作。
Like I said, your job right now is to get yourself well again so that you can go back out there and kind of do all the things again. Or it might be that you're like, this work is really part of the problem. I need to find something else to do, but you're going to need to find the energy to do all of that as well. And I think the next thing I want to talk to you about is the idea that our productivity gets so tangled up with our self-worth. It's that idea that if I'm not producing something, completing something, doing something, achieving something, you know, properly earning my money, then it isn't enough. I'm not enough. I'm not validated. I'm not, you know, who I'm used to being.
就像我说的，你现在的工作是让自己恢复健康，这样你才能回到岗位上，重新做所有的事情。或者可能你会觉得，这份工作确实是问题的一部分。我需要找点别的事情做，但你也需要找到精力去完成这一切。我想和你谈的下一件事是，我们的生产力与自我价值感纠缠在一起。这是一种观念：如果我没有产出什么，没有完成什么，没有做点什么，没有实现什么，你知道，没有真正赚到钱，那么我就不够好。我做得不够。我没有得到认可。我不是我习惯成为的那个人。
Again, we need to just take a little look and just think, right, right now, my productivity, I'm allowing myself to perhaps be less productive than I usually would be, because I'm trusting that that's part of my story to becoming well again. So it's just accepting and tolerating that, even if it feels a little bit tricky. Now I want to talk to you about that urge to kind of prove that you're really, really ill. And I'm going to give you a little example from when I was off sick after losing my own dad. And I was doing some really unusual things. And on the days where my children were at school or at the childminders, where I would usually be at work,
同样，我们需要审视一下，想一想，好吧，现在，我允许自己比平时效率低一些，因为我相信这是我恢复健康过程的一部分。所以，即使感觉有点棘手，也要接受并容忍这一点。现在我想和你谈谈那种想要证明自己真的病得很重的心态。我要举一个我自己在失去父亲后请病假时的例子。我当时做了一些非常不寻常的事情。在我的孩子们上学或在保姆那里的日子里，我通常会在工作，
it gave me time to do other things. You know, I was learning how to make soap in my kitchen at one point, but, you know, I couldn't be comparing and contrasting that to the job that I do as a qualified clinical psychologist. So just because I'm well enough to follow a simple recipe to make soap doesn't mean that I'm able to hold a clinical caseload of risk and, you know, of responsibility of running supervision sessions, of going to supervision sessions, because those two jobs are very, very different. So, you know, me being able to spend time producing something, you know, and immersed in an activity like making soap, gave me a break from the pressures of my work and was all part of my recovery. So do try
这给了我时间去做其他事情。你知道，有一次我甚至在厨房里学习做肥皂，但是，我不能把这与我作为一名合格临床心理学家的工作进行比较。所以，仅仅因为我身体状况良好，可以按照简单的食谱做肥皂，并不意味着我有能力处理临床风险病例，承担主持督导会议的责任，或者去参加督导会议，因为这两份工作是非常非常不同的。所以，我能够花时间去产出一些东西，沉浸在像做肥皂这样的活动中，让我从工作的压力中得到了喘息，这都是我康复的一部分。所以请尽量
not to kind of constantly be like, oh, well, if you've gone out for a walk, then it must mean that you're well enough to be at work, because I really do think that those two things are not the same. I also want to check that you definitely are off. work because actually keeping an eye on your emails, on your phone or on your work laptop or you know occasionally logging into teams or seeing how your workflow is going that is not that is not sick leave. If you're on sick leave all of that should be parked over here or parked with someone else to get them to do that. If you are on sick leave you are not meant to be doing any of those things because you're not well enough to be doing them. And I know, I know, I know,
不要总是觉得，哦，如果你出去散步了，那就一定意味着你身体好到可以去工作了，因为我真的认为这两件事是不一样的。我还想确认你确实是在休病假，因为实际上，盯着你的电子邮件、手机或工作笔记本电脑，或者偶尔登录 Teams 查看工作流程，那不是病假。如果你在休病假，所有这些都应该被搁置，或者交给别人去处理。如果你在休病假，你不应该做任何这些事情，因为你的身体状况不足以做这些。我知道，我知道，我知道，
I know that being disconnected from that or feeling like you can trust other people to do things, that can be really hard. But we need to know that if you're off sick, you're likely not even insured to be doing some of those things as well. So it's really empowering yourself to stay boundary to not keep checking in, to not keep doing part of your job, unless that's what you've been agreed that you're going to do, unless you're doing some sort of phased return program, there should be a very different setting between you working and you not working. So I really just want you to make sure that you are in work off mode, not work on, partially on mode. I want you to just really be honest with yourself. Recovery really isn't something that you need to
我知道与工作断开连接，或者觉得你可以信任别人去处理事情，这可能真的很难。但我们需要知道，如果你在休病假，你很可能甚至没有保险去处理其中一些事情。所以，这真的是要赋予自己力量去设定界限，不要一直查看，不要一直做你工作的一部分，除非这是你们商定好的，除非你正在进行某种分阶段回归计划，否则你在工作和不工作之间应该有非常明显的界限。所以我真的只是想确保你处于“工作关闭”模式，而不是“工作开启”或“部分开启”模式。我希望你对自己诚实。康复真的不是你需要
perform efficiently. You don't need to cram every second of the day with, you know, useful, productive things. Like it really, it really isn't that. You know, a day where you spent genuinely resting or maybe gently moving your body, you know, nourishing yourself with some homemade food or something healthy, you know, the other day I went to the shop and I just walked there and I'm picked up some pre-slice watermelon and it was so delicious. You know, a day spent nourishing yourself. Obviously, that's not all I ate that day. A day where you're able to start rebuilding those blocks is really, really important. And I really, as a last thought, want you to have a think about chunks of sick leave. Obviously, different employers will vary, but when it comes
高效执行的事情。你不需要把每一秒都塞满有用的、富有成效的事情。真的不是这样。你知道，有一天你真正地休息了，或者也许轻轻地活动了身体，用一些自制的食物或健康的东西滋养自己，你知道，前几天我去了商店，我只是走过去，买了一些切好的西瓜，它太美味了。你知道，花一天时间滋养自己。显然，那不是我那天吃的全部。能够开始重建这些基础的一天是非常非常重要的。最后，我想让你考虑一下病假的周期。显然，不同的雇主会有所不同，但当涉及到
to the NHS, often it's better to have one period of sick leave rather than multiple. multiple events of sick leave. So what I don't want is for all the guilt, the pressure, the shame, the worry about what's happening at work when you're not there, to mount up in your kind of pressure list to get you back to work sooner than you're ready to be there. What we want is for when you return to work, for you to be able to, you know, maybe do a phased return, but to start to thrive, to actually enjoy being back with your colleagues, to enjoy doing the work that you have chosen as your career.
英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）时，通常最好是一次性休完病假，而不是多次休病假。所以我不想让你所有的内疚、压力、羞耻感，以及当你不在时对工作情况的担忧，堆积在你的压力清单上，让你在还没准备好之前就匆忙回到工作岗位。我们希望的是，当你重返工作岗位时，你能够进行分阶段回归，开始茁壮成长，真正享受与同事在一起的时光，享受你选择作为职业的工作。
and to help that enrich your life not detract from it. So I really want to make sure that by the time you go back to work, that you really are well enough to be there, or certainly curious about whether that will, your current wellness will be sustained. So I appreciate that workplace HR and, you know, how much sick leave you've had in the past and whether you even get paid sick leave at all
并让它丰富你的生活，而不是削弱它。所以我真的想确保当你回到工作岗位时，你确实身体状况良好，或者至少对你目前的健康状况能否持续持审慎态度。我知道工作场所的人力资源部门，以及你过去休了多少病假，甚至你是否能获得带薪病假，
And if you're self-employed like me, you don't often, that that might mean that you're going back to work sooner. But if you're employed and you do get good sick leave policies, good sick leave pain, just make sure that you genuinely are well enough to be back at work. Thank you so much for watching or listening to this episode of Inner Work. I would love to know what you think. If you've enjoyed this episode of Inner Work, I think you might also really enjoy the one on safety and why that might be what we're striving for.
如果你像我一样是自雇人士，你通常没有，这可能意味着你会更早回到工作岗位。但如果你是受雇的，并且确实有很好的病假政策和病假工资，只要确保你真的身体状况良好，可以回到工作岗位。非常感谢你观看或收听这一期的《内在工作》。我很想知道你的想法。如果你喜欢这一期的《内在工作》，我想你可能也会喜欢关于安全感以及为什么那可能是我们所追求的目标的那一期。
The next episode of Inner Work will be along at 8pm UK time. Thanks so much for being part of my world. Do be kind to yourself. I'll see you soon. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下一期《内在工作》将于英国时间晚上 8 点播出。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。请善待自己。我们很快再见。保重。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。